on va refermer ce 7 8 en parlant de
danse et je le disais tout à l'heure la
mission danse de 50 ans Nîmes le
scarabée également s'associe pour
proposer un week-end 100% hip-hop samedi
et dimanche à La Verrière il fera déjà
vous êtes avec nous pour en parler
danseur et chorégraphe
50 ans en Yvelines on le disait aussi en
début d'émission territoire pionnier du
mouvement hip-hop de la danse hip-hop en
France avec cette compagnie les Black
blurber qui ont été fondées en 1983 par
Jean gemmaad et Christine Coudin vous en
avez fait partie vous avez été danseur
de cette compagnie c'est important oui
pour vous de revenir régulièrement sur
le territoire de rappeler cette histoire
une histoire aussi qui a continué il y a
un héritage beaucoup d'associations de
compagnies aujourd'hui pratiques
justement cette danse hip-hop
aujourd'hui tout à fait c'est
l'angle de la transmission transmettre
ce flambeau
également pour que la cette mémoire ne
tombe pas dans l'oubli cet héritage ne
tombe pas donc
créer des vocations également chez les
chez les plus jeunes
un avenir un avenir à construire
également des projections de l'espoir
c'est quelque chose qui me tient à cœur
cet ancrage sur le territoire et en tout
cas il y a des bons géants qui ont été
accomplis parce qu'on lui disait aussi
le breakdance qui est l'un des styles du
hip-hop on le disait tout à l'heure va
faire son entrée au JO sera une
discipline additionnelle des JO l'an
prochain qui dérouleront bien sûr du
côté de Paris vous le voyez comment vous
cette entrée du breakdance aux Jeux
Olympiques ce que vous le voyez dans
d'un bon œil est-ce que ça peut
peut-être favoriser la
professionnalisation un peu plus de
professionnalisation de la discipline
tout à fait je le vois sous d'un bon œil
d'autant plus que au delà de la
professionnalisation c'est la sécurité
également dans la dans la pratique et
voilà de des projections un avenir aussi
pour pour ces jeunes ambitieux qui
cherchent leur voix
et donc on le disait gros week-end
hip-hop au programme à La Verrière avec
deux jours au programme atelier battle
spectacle l'idée c'était justement vous
parliez transmission c'est ça s'adresse
à tout le monde ce week-end aussi bien
des non initiés au hip-hop des personnes
qui souhaitent se perfectionner aussi
peut-être c'est pour tout le monde ce
weekend tout à fait et ouvert à la
famille également puisque c'est
fédérateurs les plus jeunes les parents
pourront apprécier les forces vives du
territoire cette créativité en mouvement
et juste pour préciser la jeunesse de ce
projet puisque nous avons sur la
deuxième édition et la première édition
a eu l'année dernière suite à une une
demande de Dominique Benaim de la
mission danse la Commanderie et donc
nous avons réfléchi ensemble à des temps
forts des temps forts qui pourraient
exister sur le territoire et
qui pourrait favoriser également
l'émergence l'émergence des des nouveaux
chorégraphes et donc au programme alors
samedi il y a trois workshop top rock
jazz rock poping looking hype les
workshops qu'est ce que c'est son des
ateliers on peut les présenter comme ça
animer par des danseurs des chorégraphes
professionnelles tout à fait c'est ce
sont des temps de pratique des temps de
pratique autour d'une technique alors en
l'occurrence nous avons le Top Rock le
Top Rock qui est tiré du breakdance qui
vient du breakdance donc ce sont
autrement dit les pas de préparation
c'est ce qui prépare à aller au sol donc
c'est toute une gestuelle qui a été
développée par des des
icônes des phares de lance de cette
esthétique notamment Masamba du baleine
accompagnée de kadiaba qui seront
présents pour défendre le Top Rock mais
également le jazz Rocard le jazz rock
c'est une
la particularité la particularité du
jazz rock c'est que c'est né en France
et nous avons ici sur le territoire de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines les faire de
lance du jazz rock et notamment sera
présent Alex Bent voilà qui transmet
cette esthétique depuis
on a vraiment des
icônes les pionniers nos aînés pour pour
nous c'était nos référents à l'époque
puisqu'à
la compagnie blackber Régine vous avez
une question justement c'est workshop
top rock jazz rock est-ce que c'est une
initiation de pas de danse si tout le
monde peut essayer enfin s'il essayait
en tout cas tout à fait tout à fait
c'est ouvert au néophyte et de la même
manière est-ce que vous expliquez aussi
en début de workshop qu'est-ce que c'est
parce que par exemple le jazz rock bah
c'est né en France c'est aussi
intéressant et de savoir il y a des
notions autour de l'histoire l'histoire
de de ces pas de danse de ces styles de
danse et c'est fondamental dans le terme
de transmission
je dirais on aime bien savoir
ce qu'on va manger quoi
voilà et là c'est pas du McDonald's
un battle chorégraphique alors battle
voilà c'est comme ça que que s'affront
je sais pas si on peut parler
d'affronter mais en tout cas ce se
retrouve les danseurs hip-hop d'ailleurs
sera des battles pour les JO de Paris
2024 là c'est un battle chorégraphique
c'est ça qu'est-ce qui est au programme
alors initialement le battle c'est la
confrontation de de groupe mais à la
fois ça peut être individuel ou à deux
et là en l'occurrence ce sont des Croux
à l'écrou autrement dit ce sont les
groupes les groupes de danse qui vont se
confronter en présentant un show un
chiot c'est une performance de une à
deux minutes percutante et voilà ce sera
le l'objet de ce battle la confrontation
de groupe et donc des groupes
accompagnés par des acteurs locaux
donc des professeurs des des
chorégraphes émergence du territoire
voilà qui vont donner à voir leur petite
pépites donc ça sera pour le programme
du samedi et alors le dimanche on pourra
observer des chorégraphies des
chorégraphes de la sunny pop c'est ça
tout à fait alors à l'issue du Battle
chorégraphique le gagnant pourra
participer à la première partie de la
scène ouverte qui aura lieu le lendemain
suivi donc et bien oui des des
chorégraphes du territoire notamment
Matthieu radiohelle junior des pétrole
junior qui présentera une pièce avec
Tessa radioheel Caroline wolcom et
Marie-Claire M'Bemba et donc c'est une
pièce chorégraphique qui s'attache au
détail lié au jugement de premier abord
ainsi qu'à la relation complexe entre
féminité et confiance en soi dans notre
société
c'est avant tout une danse d'auteur qui
sera présentée et c'était cette
émergence qui était dans l'ombre et bien
au travers de cet événement sera mis en
lumière et voilà il y aura donc Mathieu
a duel mais également la compagnie des
gamma les gamins qui sont
des icônes de la danse hip-hop
aujourd'hui
et qui
franchit pas de la création et qui nous
présenterons un créa chaud alors c'est à
la frontière entre la création
artistique et le show le show percutant
performant qu'on peut voir souvent dans
les bateaux
et également dans l'arène la compagnie
grecz
Deadman et de Yanka Pedron qui sont tous
deux les fers de lance de la danse
debout notamment du popping
et d'un style particulier le tutting
programme riche pour ce week-end hip-hop
on peut retrouver toutes les
informations sur le site de 50 ans en
Yvelines qui va s'afficher en bas de
l'écran et donc c'est 25 26 mars toutes
les inscriptions sont closes on peut
s'inscrire encore on peut s'inscrire
donc c'est la bonne nouvelle ça vous
attire peut-être la gym salut pourquoi
pas pour ce week-end 100% hip-hop merci
en tout cas il fera direct d'être venu
en parler en plateau je rappelle danseur
et chorégraphe et à l'origine avec la
mission danse de 50 ans en une avec le
scarabée de ce week-end 100% hip-hop à
Saint-Quentin en